o bom dia amigos e é grato por poder
partilhar algumas reflexões breve
então não vou contar a história da minha
vida mas vou dizer que há 40 anos atrás
eu levava sete anos de trabalho como
professor
quando alguém vai para o professor vai
por uma de duas razões
ao que consta foi por amor por vingança
é verdade eu confesso que eu fui por
vingança
fiquei por amor porque o ato de educar
um ato do vínculo amoroso
porém foi por vingança porque a minha
experiência enquanto o aluno é uma
experiência de humilhação e de exclusão
por ter nascido no lugar enfim isso e
dizer estrábico e tetra hoje falas
bíblia mas o frio naquela época e foi
excluído
então eu jurei jurei a mim mesmo em
galho ou seja quando fosse professor
nenhum aluno meu passaria pelas
situações de exclusão que eu tinha
passado
porém durante sete anos de escola em
escola dando o meu melhor como qualquer
professor faz preparava muito lá em
planejava as minhas aulas preparava
materiais muito bons ao que diziam
alguns mas todos os anos havia alunos
que não aprendeu que reprovava eu
excluiria até que surgiu essa coisa que
há pouco foi falado da escola da ponte
escolas aponta uma mutação genética no
sistema educativo mundial e aconteceu
foi muito simples com gente igual a mim
frágil velhinha ficaram mais jovens já
tinham muitos anos mesmo ea dois
episódios que marcaram bastante
mostraram a resposta à pergunta que eu
fazia porque eu dou aula tão bem dada e
alunos que não aprender um dia com
outros
eu descobri a resposta se eu dou aula
eles não aprendem
elas não aprendem porque eu dou aula aí
a coisa complicou se
eu só sabia dar aula e criança não é
cobaia de laboratório continuar dando
aula porém com mais duas pessoas a quem
eu devo a minha relação da cultura
pessoal e profissional porque o projeto
mas não um projeto coletivo
ninguém sozinho faz o que quer que seja
eu tive duas situações que usou na área
que me explicar o porquê
a primeira foi uma criança que um dia
ela me pediu para ajudar e eu fui junto
dela e ela perguntou professora é vedada
a quem um ser vivo é que opinasse creche
do produto se move
nessa altura eu já não dava resposta é
perguntas que lhe foram feitas como
agora estou a fazer
imagine quais são as perguntas bastante
por aí não sei se serão estas que nossas
respostas mas como a regra é falar sem
ouvir a pergunta eu respeito à regra
então a criança perguntou me e disse por
que pergunta se isso é que eu tenho
dúvida mas qual é se um ser vivo é o que
está nos livros
eu sei que nas creches de produtos
imóvel
eu não concordo fiquei muito aliviado
com o jovem simultaneamente alegra
porque já tinha aprendido não tenha
assinado mas irritado porque eu tenho a
dar 60 anos e ensinar o ser vivo e punha
no quadro negro ser vivo seis pontos ao
canal express pelos irmãos mas pecavam
uma imagem mostrava nascimento e aquela
jovem foi descoberto num bom aí o
o que está errado e outros prêmios o
processo se um ser vivo é aquela que
nasce cresce e produz igual então é não
só um ser vivo em não reproduzirem
morrer você também não
aquilo mexeu comigo mexeu comigo aí eu
perguntei 'quem quer ser um ser vivo eu
quero
e aí eu fui com ela fazer um projeto não
ficar por aqui neste episódio que é mais
longo
pouco tempo depois nós estávamos a fazer
a astronomia à noite porque aquela
escola não tem horário a gente encontra
se a aprender uns com os outros em
qualquer horário
estamos a fazer astronomia e uma senhora
chegou junto de mim
uma mãe de uma aluna e disse o professor
a minha filha de três anos outra escola
quando vai para a ponta é prender o
goleiro que não aprendeu em três anos
ela sabe ler
eu estou com problema qual é a minha
senhora eu não sei ler a então esse
problema sua filha agora sabemos não ias
plano é outro sabe mas eu não sei como
explicar
shampoo ao lado deles pai se muito em
vós o meu marido chega muito tarde na
casa eu disse que trabalha a tentar nos
vamos desconfiada mas porque eu tenho os
papéis do idoso
como eu gostava de saber ler não vou
perguntar a minha filha não é seguir a
carreira eu quero é então eu disse então
terá um papel ela diz não vai ser
difícil é melhor conta
passados dois dias trouxe um dos papéis
que o marido tenha nos bolsos do paletó
mostrou uma papel lhe diz a lei a
professora se eu não a senhora que vai
ler mas eu não sei vamos aprender e
fomos aprendendo ao fim de talvez dois
meses ela jogou um dia a fim de tentar
da casa chegava ao fim da tarde eles
professor eu acho que já sei ler acho
que já sei eu saber está com um ar tão
triste é que se for aquilo que eu penso
ela sentou se jogou no papel nós
tínhamos visto várias vezes a cartilha
dell era que o papel que o marido tinha
no bolso do paletó ea o leu
e eu aqui eu não é eu você tem 16 anos é
meu é meu é meu a
o professor não é pra mim sabe bom ela
aprendeu em dois meses e superou no
terceiro mesmo ela e mais se possa então
aprendi mais uma coisa é que a
aprendizagem acontece quando ela é
significativa
ou seja quando eu quero onde eu sei
porque é que aprendo e mais aprendizagem
emancipatória e mais ela tem que ser
partilhada
num ato de avaliação onde encaixar com
isto tudo é que eu percebi numa metáfora
que a escola teria de mudar ou melhor eu
teria de mudar porque a escola não é um
edifício escolas são pessoas são pessoas
as pessoas são os seus valores sua visão
de sociedade essa visão do mundo o seu
conceito pessoa humana e as pessoas agem
em função dos princípios e os princípios
conduzam uma prática do projeto teve
nota comportamentos forma onde tudo se a
escola brasileira
o mundial fosse aquela que seria
necessária e não essa que nós temos não
teríamos políticos corruptos não
estaríamos com a mata ciliar ciliar e
amazonas é destruída
não veríamos 150 brasileiros serão
assassinados por dia
então eu perguntava como é que podemos
mudar e eu descobri a escola tem tudo o
que precisa para mudar eu plantava
porque é que não muda e então eu aprendi
a primeira grande dificuldade sou eu a
minha cultura pessoal profissional uma
cultura de solidão sala da aula foi
herdada através do leite materno e
através de uma formação reproduzir o
modelo social escolar e é muito difícil
mudar porque o segundo grande inimigo é
outro professor que também é o grande
aliado
mas quando faz diferente é dentro da
escola que surja a reação
outra dificuldade os alunos estão
habituados a ouvir a aula é mais fácil
do que está se esforçado é pesquisar e
aprender
depois a sociedade os pais que pensam
que a escola tem que ser como sempre foi
e não foi sempre assim
ela só é assim desde a revolução
industrial na inglaterra uma pensão
prussiana e arias ea francesa os estados
versão surge então a sociedade pensa que
a escola tem que ser como foi é como a
síndrome de gabriela eu nasci assim eu
fui sempre assim você fazer não é
não tem de ser é bem diferente um dia
perguntaram a miguel ângelo aquilo que
fez está davi que foi à frente e sabe
que estou a falar uma coisa curiosa foi
possível que um ser humano fizesse uma
coisa daquelas
eudes foi fácil e não foi fácil como
então 11 está tão grande tão bela tão
profeta eo no clássico deixou fácil para
o problema mas como foi fácil foi
simples
eu olhei pro bloco de mármore imaginei
miquelângelo dentro do bloco
depois foi só tirar tudo que não era me
olhava e ficou na av
ou seja é preciso tirar tudo aquilo que
a escola hoje tem para ficar na escola a
escola e grega
bom a 3 grande eu mais uma série de
episódios eu
bom vou citar apenas 11 dias se o
chegaram sete jovens jogados fora das
escolas e que já tinham passado pela fé
bem para a fundação casa
sete jovens que já tinham matado tenham
posto professora estado como noutra
escola enfim eu por exemplo sentarem
para não ter que eles queriam fazer deus
disseram que os outros falam me deixava
fazer nada como é que ele poderia fazer
crer que quisesse
eles podem dizer ao crash e uma jovem
diz que tenham os pássaros na febem e
gostava de jogar na escola segundo a
escola e ela aceitava ficar porque
nenhuma escola já o santos a colher
adicione mais por espaços eu não sei
eles mais velho em o trabalho na
construção civil não sabe eu quando
estou a dar tiros as pessoas eu trabalho
na construção civil e um dia fez um um
viveiro para passas muito bonito só
ficava ganha letal
estamos fazer sair e vai fazer sozinho
não tá aqui a galera tem 17
eu tenho um projecto e uma equipe
perguntei como é que é o viveiro olha
temos uma base de betão uma cantoneira
de alumínio perguntei quanto a
cantoneira não sei então apanhei o que
eu preciso saber para fazer reviver
saber medir um metro múltiplos e
submúltiplos sempre calcula despesa
saber como salienta uma planta saber o
que é a proporcionalidade direta à volta
o que tem até em uma tela quantos metros
quadrados não sei campanha precisa saber
calcular a área do retângulo metro
quadrado da área
qual é o passo com o predador ao fim de
meia hora eu tenha construído um projeto
e um roteiro de estudo para pesquisa com
74 conteúdos da grade curricular que
eles precisavam saber para fazer o
projeto eo violeiro fizeram nove dias e
partilharam com os outros tudo aquilo
que sabia então meus amigos isto vai
provando uma coisa é que o brasil tem
tudo que precisa para anunciar a boa
nova a mais de 200 projetos que o
conhecem muitos outros que não ignora
que estão aí para mostrar que é possível
uma outra escola uma escola que tem
alunos do século 21 não a trabalhar como
o século 19 mas comprou seu século 20 a
trabalhar como se exige que esse
trabalho há três condições a primeira
cuidar dos professores cuidados
professor significa elevar o seu
estatuto social dar um salário digno uma
formação oportunidades relação cultural
segunda e essa é mais difícil
reconfigurar as práticas é que está o
problema é um problema gravíssimo
quando eu falo que numa aula não ser
treinada as duas ficam em dúvida
eu dizia está há 40 anos diziam que eu
era jovem o tópico quando fosse maior
taxação maior e continua a pensar o
mesmo o melhor a fazer o mesmo ou seja
numa aula
nada se aprender e quando alguém
contesta aqui não podemos estar a
conversar mas as pessoas dizem não não
eu aprendi na aula eu pergunto a senhora
sabe fazer raiz quadrada alguém aqui só
foi recuperada tiveram aulas sobre os
cuidados e fizeram prova não sabe sabe
qual é forma particular para calcular o
volume da esfera
não sabem andar na escola no fundamental
deram ao longo da esfera não sabe sabem
o anunciar o princípio de coriolis
também não sabe mas tiveram lá e tiveram
aulas sobre meus amigos é um tabu
isso é doloroso que eu saiba 99% das
pessoas são educadores brasileiros dão
aula
meus amigos numa aula não se aprende
nada apenas se acumula cognitivamente
para fazer uma prova e uma prova não
prova nada porque vós fizestes provas 3
quadrado e fez tudo certinho e não
sabemos fazê las
é doloroso porque as forças que se faz é
puro sofrimento porque para além das
famílias da sociedade ao poder público
que muitas vezes é contrário a essa
mudança
isso eu entendo porque apesar de ser
português bom então e foi a criança
grande que se manifestou para a terceira
na cidade a primeira cuidados
professoras a segunda reconfigurar a
prática ou seja modificar totalmente no
século 21
ter uma escola que tem aula é um absurdo
um escândalo em escândalo científico
porque nós temos no brasil autores
cientistas da educação
grande favorito lauro de oliveira lima
paulo freire
porém vai ao fim da silva maria viu
tanta gente que as pessoas desconhecem
então a terceira grande na cidade é
considere desenvolver uma nova
construção social de aprendizagem onde o
nome da comunidade de aprendizagem
comunidade
pessoas que conhecem pessoas com
necessidades específicas que partilham o
conhecimento que produzem para melhorar
as suas vidas com a escola ea escola aí
é um nódulo de uma rede de aprendizagem
é um projeto desenvolvimento do carro a
escola pode ser um motor de configuração
da sociedade se institucionalmente
exportarem pensando se dado então como
eu sempre te leva para casa um professor
por deixar alguma tarefa para casa tá
bom
depois se um dia voltar já vinha
participando áreas são de voltar
voltaremos às perguntas que vão fazer
então a primeira pergunta é porque aí é
porque é que a aula porque é que a
escola faz férias
se a igreja não faz férias o hospital
não faço é que a escola faz feliz porque
é que mal tem 50 minutos será a primeira
linha prontas
a segunda é porque os pais mais
conscientes tirar os filhos da escola
pública e espanha numa escola particular
tenha possibilidade de tirar e aqueles
que não têm possibilidades que ficou lá
será justo num país que se quer fraterno
e igualitário eu existo porque vou
desistir
eu não posso ser feliz o outro não é
minha última tarefa para casa
aristóteles um grande que influenciou
toda a ciência da idade média
eu tenho escrito vários tratados sobre
ser vivo se inscrever num dos tratados
o seguinte a mosca doméstica a mostra
mais que possui oito patas e durante
séculos os copistas foram passando de
papiro para papiro a verdade estou
técnica
a mostra doméstica possui oito patas
amostras mas até que um dia o fraco
pista já animado a 1 e vem espírito
científico e operou até o momento pousou
a pena de ganso e foi procurar uma mosca
ganhou a mosca olhou e presumiu que ela
estivesse amputada
aí apanhou mais algumas ao fim de 6 12
mostras eu voltou era o seu espaço de
trabalho por onde a pena escreveu a
mosca doméstica possui seis patas então
tarefa para casa contar para as músicas
ficar em paz